welcome back to CBS this morning
Minneapolis police chief Madera
arredondo is calling on the city's
police union to reform the department
after the killing of George Floyd during
a 60 Minutes interview on Sunday night
or a doughnut arredondo rather blame the
police union its contract and its leader
that's lieutenant Bob Kroll for making
reform difficult he and others are going
to have to come to a reckoning that
either they are going to be on the right
side of history or they're going to be
in the wrong side of history but or they
will be left behind in an interview
you'll see first on CBS this morning we
spoke with lieutenant Crowell and three
fellow union leaders yesterday that was
rich Walker senior Sheryl Schmidt and
Anna Hedberg can I get your response to
what the chief said Sunday night we
believe that our membership that we are
elected to represent has been unfairly
scapegoated by political leaders in our
city and our state and they have shifted
their incompetent leadership failed
leadership on to us and our members and
it's simply unjust so here is our
opportunity to hopefully set the record
straight we will be on the right side of
history before this incident happened we
had some great conversation occurring
with with the city leaders and with the
Chiefs and we were making some good
progress on the contract so it's just
dumbfounding to me that one incident we
become the scapegoat to having a bad
officer let's talk about the incident
because it has certainly become a global
a global conversation I want to know
from each of you what you thought when
you saw the video of George Floyd and
officer Chauvin that's part of the
problem Gail is we were not allowed to
see the video the administration broke
our policy which gives us the ability to
review the video so we were blindsided
we only saw the social media video in
all other officer involved critical
incidents we're entitled to review and
this what I've seen of it is only what
the public is seen on the cell phone and
it's
rific how much more do you need to see
to determine to come out and say that
this is not alright any human being that
watch that knows that that shouldn't
ended the way it did but we also know
that there's more to the story they say
he never resisted in the statements
release we don't know if he never
resisted because we haven't seen from
the time the officers stopped him and to
the point where he was on the ground but
are you also saying to us that you can't
really make a comment about this case
until you see every piece of video
associated with it is that what you're
saying today we would just like to see
what we are entitled to in our agreement
in our policy is our officers body
camera footage it may shed some light
that we're unaware of right now we
cannot make an informed decision
regarding the other officers that do not
appear on camera okay can you understand
why that answer what you're saying right
now is extremely upsetting to people who
have seen this case heard the charges
looked at the tape that we have seen can
you understand from the public point of
view why it's upsetting silence again
that we're not gonna say anything
negative about a fellow officer even
though what you're looking and seeing
with your own eyes seems especially
heinous and especially egregious
certainly we would love to have seen
more we just we saw the initial
statement from the administration which
was wrong and this has been invaded
exercised in leadership here and we we
wish we could have an early opinion in
this but it's up to the administration
to stick with policy and give us what
we're entitled to under policy it does
look and sound horrible I completely
agree with you Gail how do you think the
situation should have been handled with
George Floyd that night I'm not one that
likes to Monday Morning Quarterback
things if I was there I probably have
put him on his side in a recovery
position once once he could went
unconscious but let's address really the
elephant in the room how black people
feel in your city that black men are
under siege by white police officers and
that they're tar
in a disproportionate rate I think
absolutely the media's pushes to drum up
as much racial issues and stress as
there's not acknowledging the fact I'm
not denying the fact that that the city
is needs to grow is it a media problem I
believe is this a media problem you're
saying the media created what I'm saying
Gil what I what I'm saying is the the
narrative that is being pushed in the
media is that white police officers are
out on these streets just to kill black
men and that is absolutely farthest from
the truth yes we have encounters with
civilians in a city that turns for the
for the worst and that's my actual
problem with some of what black lives
matter I actually believe in what black
lives matter stand for but it should
stand all the time not just when a
police officer or white police officer
or an Asian police officer has a fatal
encounter with with the unarmed person
we're not defending the actions of mr.
Shelvin what happened to mr. Floyd is a
tragedy but we weren't out there what
we're saying is the narrative needs to
stop it needs to stop police officers
are not out here just randomly hunting
black people to kill them that's that's
terrible yep we think that's terrible to
all of the officers felt very
comfortable as you see sitting close to
each other during the interview because
they told us that they're all
quarantined together we should also note
that lieutenant Bob Kroll is married to
anchor Liz Collin of our Minneapolis
station WCCO so he has a he has an idea
about how the media works and they were
all very forthcoming in their opinions
about what they had to say right now the
negotiations between the police chief in
the Union are not happening because the
police chief has broken off the
negotiations with the Union which is
interesting when lieutenant Bob Cole
said to us yesterday that he and the
chief are actually good friends yes that
they have a good working relationship
and he's hoping because you can't go
anywhere without negotiation I was
surprised I think the best relationship
he's ever had yeah I was surprised to
hear that
so we'll see hopefully the two sides
have got to figure out a way to get back
to the table yeah